ja willkommen zu aktuellen Vorlesung wie
immer sie ahnen schon brauchst
eigentlich gar nicht mehr sagen dieses
Unmögliche begriffsnetz und da haben wir
noch ein paar
sind noch ein paar Fragen gekommen
meine Tutorin haben mich noch was
hingewiesen und zwar gibt es da wohl
noch ein bisschen Nachfragen zu diesem
Bereich links unten wie das sich mit
dieser Indifferenz genau verhält und mit
der termination und dann auch mit der
Position des Determinismus also wenn man
sagt der terminismus oder alles mit mit
dieser Endung
Kapitalismus das sind Positionen
ja und hier oben spreche ich jetzt mit
Ausnahme eigentlich vom Indeterminismus
nicht so sehr von Positionen sondern von
Zuständen also der libertarierismus ist
eine philosophische Position der harte
Determinismus ist eine Position und
jetzt kann man sich natürlich fragen wie
verhält sich Indifferenz zu ich müsste
hier vielleicht genauer schreiben in der
termination ja das ist eine gute Frage
in der domination heißt einfach dass ein
Zustand nicht determiniert ist nicht
eindeutig festgelegt ist man könnte zum
Beispiel sagen es gibt nur
Wahrscheinlichkeitsverteilung ne keine
Eindeutigkeit und Indifferenz ist ganz
in die terminismus Indifferenz ist aber
etwas was stärker auf das Problem des
Grundes bezogen ist ja also jemand ist
Indifferenz wenn es kein überwiegenden
Grund gibt und man würde auch
Indifferenz eigentlich nicht auf
natürliche Zustände beziehen also Sache
natürlichen Zustand unter Umständen
sprechen können davon dass sie
indeterminiert sind wenn man zum
Beispiel Quanten Zustände sich anschaut
oder irgendwelche anderen Phänomene wo
man keine Ursachen finden kann also eher
auf Natur bezogen die Indifferenz
bezieht sich ihr dann wenn es um die
Gründe geht sie erinnern sich noch an
diesen Esel Buche Dance Esel der vor
zwei gleich großen Heuhaufen steht und
der vor verhungert weil er keinen
überwiegenden Grund hat oder wenn ich
sage die Sache ist mir völlig gleich ich
werfe eine Münze egal was rauskommt ich
bin völlig indifferent es gibt keinen
überwiegenden Grund so können sich die
Interferenz merken ja ich bin also was
das Gründe Gleichgewicht angelangt
völlig in Differenz wenn ich alle Gründe
Abwege die Gründe Brote konnte auf die
Waagschale dann hält sich das im
Gleichgewicht manche spricht man auch
von equilibrismus oder also
gleichgewichtrium ist das Gleichgewicht
stellen sich immer diese Metapher der
Gründe Wagen also Indifferenz immer mit
Bezug auf Stunde in der terminismus
heißt etwas ist nicht der terminiert das
ist natürlich dann der Gegenbegriff zu
der termination oder genau gesagt hier
zum Determinismus entweder entweder ist
etwas determiniert vollständig oder
nicht
und jetzt kann man anhand dieser
Spielarten eben sehr schön
kompatibilismus sind inkompatibilismus
diskutieren immer mit Blick auf die
Frage sind Willensfreiheit und der
terminismus oder der termination
vertragen die sich können die
miteinander koexistieren kriegen wir die
auf einen Begriff oder auf Männer und
die Position die sagt das geht nicht die
wird genannt inkompatibilismus jetzt ist
aber der Witz dabei der nicht jeder der
inkompatibel ist ist auf diese Frage
Verhältnis der termination und
willenseits nicht jeder der sagt das ist
inkompatibel muss dadurch die Freiheit
bestreiten das ist so der Witz der Sache
man kann nämlich auch noch ein lieber
tarianismus vertreten man kann also
sagen Determinationen Willen selbst
vertragen sich nicht aber dennoch sind
wir willensfrei warum weil die Position
des Determinismus falsch ist weil es
einfach nicht der Fall ist dass alles
determiniert ist in der Welt zum
Beispiel durch die Naturgesetzen und
dann kann ich mich wenn ich diese
Position vertrete kann ich mich zum
Beispiel auf sowas in der terminismus
berufen dass ich sage es gibt Zustände
Natur die sind nicht durch das die
Naturgesetze vollständig der terminiert
ich kann aber vielleicht sogar auch
Bezug nehmen zu sowas wie
indifferentismus und sagen meine Gründe
die mich für mein Handeln antreiben die
Gründe die von meinen Handeln mein
Freihandel eine Rolle spielt diese
Gründe wenn sie mich zu etwas bewegen
die kann ich nicht adäquaten sind das
der terminismus verstehen das heißt wenn
Gründe für mich überwiegend sind für
eine Handlung in dieser wahlschale dann
ist es nicht der terministisch zu
verstehen sondern dann passiert etwas
anderes das betrifft wieder die Frage
wie man sich Gründe vorstellen kann sind
Gründe dasselbe die Ursachen kausale
Ursachen oder sind Gründe nicht noch ein
bisschen was anderes Gründe kann ich
zurechtlegen Gründe kann ich
reflektieren Gründe kann nicht
gegeneinander abwägen ja also Gründe
eine riesendebatte wir gehen aber auch
nicht näher drauf ein oder sie wissen
hier spielen dann immer auf Gründe eine
Rolle Gründe versus Naturgesetze das ist
die Frage die diese dieses Thema hier
unten betrifft und ein harte der
terminismus sagt einfach Nein
willenseitig und der termination
vertragen sich nicht
aber willenseits ist falsch und der
Determinismus ist wahr ne also ist immer
die Frage wie verhält man sich zum
Verhältnis zu determination und
Willensfreiheit in kompatibilismus heißt
nicht dass wir notwendige Weise sein
haben Determinismus vertreten müssen
weil wir ja auch ähm ein die Batterien
ist muss vertreten können wir haben
darüber mal eine Frage diskutiert und
deswegen natürlich eine Frage des Typs
ja wenn man dann sich fragt was sind die
Gründe für übertarianismus oder gegen
ihn genauso kann man auch die Frage
stellen mit Blick auf den harten
Determinismus was spricht dafür diese
Annahme zu tätigen was spricht dagegen
es gibt Gründe dafür und dagegen sie
können sich denken was dagegen spricht
natürlich unsere Intuitionen alles
natürlich harte terminiert ist und es
keine Willensfreiheit gibt dann
konfligieren damit wichtige Intuitionen
die wir haben sehen sie noch an diese
Diskussion dieses Textes von Wolf singer
Hirnforschung und Willensfreiheit und
sein Gehirn unsere neuronalen
verschaltuhren legen uns fest wie sieht
es dann aus wenn es um die moralische
oder normative Bewertung von Handlungen
geht wenn wir dann nur letztendlich dem
Naturgesetz unterliegen und irgendwie
gar keine freien Alternativen
Entscheidungsmöglichkeiten haben immer
Gründe dafür und dagegen dafür spricht
natürlich für den harten Determinismus
dass man den wunderbar mit der
Naturwissenschaften ein Verhältnis
bringen kann man kann alles perfekt
berechnen und Vorhersagen das heißt
unser Rationalität ideal alles muss
berechenbar sein durch Naturgesetz und
gewisse Zustände und sonstige regeln das
ist natürlich im Determinismus erfüllt
dadurch wird natürlich unser Handeln
vollständig verständlich und
kalkulierbar die Frage ist halt ob das
am Ende dann noch unsere Intuition von
Willensfreiheit entspricht ja wir sehen
da gibt es viel Diskussionsmöglichkeiten
und falls eine solche Frage dran kommt
würde natürlich noch konkreter gestellt
werden und wird tief den Fragetyp B
betreffen so dass ich hier auch ein
Gewissen Freiheitsspielraum haben in der
Argumentation auch und konnte
ja dann sind wir weiter gegangen und wir
sind eigentlich auch schon Ende also
dieses begriffsnetz wird auch gar nicht
weiter mehr gefüllt werden wir sind
eigentlich schon am Ende und zwar
deswegen weil wir heute noch mal
verstärkt auf das Böse gehen und dann
den Begriff der Selbsttäuschung den habe
ich auch schon mit aufgenommen hier an
den sehen Sie hier den habe ich jetzt in
den Kontext von Willensschwäche gestellt
obwohl es nicht dasselbe ist aber das
ist in einem Widerspruch zu Vernunft
stehend ja warum sollten wir uns selbst
täuschen ja jeder möchte doch eigentlich
die Wahrheit wissen und auch über sich
selbst ja man was spricht eigentlich
dafür sowas anzunehmen willenschwäche
scheint auch irgendwie Phänomen zu sein
Donald Davidson hat darüber viel
geschrieben wir müssen es irgendwie
annehmen obwohl es eigentlich völlig
irrational ist warum sollten wir eine
Handlung tun wenn alle unsere Gründe
gegen die Handlung sprechen ja
eigentlich tun wir doch das wofür alle
unsere Gründe sprechen unter allen mit
Umständen die wir in der Bewegung ziehen
können und trotzdem tun wir die
Alternative und das ist übernacht Donald
Davidson village darüber wollen wir auch
noch ein bisschen diskutieren ob man das
Böse und darauf kommen jetzt gleich noch
näher zu sprechen ob der Begriff des
Bösen überhaupt sinnvoll ist
handlungstheoretisch aber wenn er
sinnvoll ist wie dann das böse
vielleicht auch verstanden werden kann
als Handlung oder Handlungsfolge oder
handlungsgrund mit Blick auf die
Rationalität also ob wir am Ende sagen
müssen wenn wir böse oder sagen wir sind
ein bisschen harmlose unmoralisch
handeln dann unterliegen wieder
Willensschwäche weil eigentlich wollen
wir doch immer das Gute tun
und jetzt könnte das unmoralisch Handel
einfallen menschliches Sein alle Gründe
sprechen natürlich für das Gute aber
trotzdem tun wir das für nicht alle
Gründe sprechen ist das dann so dass
unmoralische vorzustellen gibt versuche
die das so erklären wollen es gibt aber
auch eine andere Möglichkeit des Böse zu
bestimmen des unmoralisch auch mit Blick
auf unsere Zurechenbarkeit auf unsere
Verantwortung dass er sagt da spielt
eine Form von Selbsttäuschung eine Rolle
wir machen uns darin was vor wir
konstruieren uns eine Welt sich
innerhalb derer unsere Absichten
plötzlich als gerechtfertigt erscheint
vielleicht sogar auch als moralisch und
sie haben schon dass es wieder das Thema
der Rationalisierung wir gehen da auch
noch ein bisschen mehr heute darauf ein
jetzt möchte ich aber ein bisschen
zurücktreten und mal auf das Problem des
Bösen eingehen ich habe nämlich in der
letzten Diskussion gemerkt der Begriff
da scheiden sich die Geister dieser
Begriff des Bösen der ist hochgradig
Problem praktisch ich habe mich aber
dennoch entschieden dieses Thema hier im
Rahmen der handlungsphilosophie der
Handlungstheorie zu behandeln und nicht
nur deswegen weil ich darüber mal ein
Buch geschrieben habe und irgendwie
Bestsellerautor werden wollte habe eh
keine Chance gegen den aktuellen
Bestsellerautor
habe ich keine Chance gibt es überhaupt
moralisch böses ist der Begriff des
moralisch bösen sinnvoll natürlich
handlungstheoretisch anders gefragt ist
der Begriff des Bösen ein möglicher
Grundbegriff der praktischen Philosophie
darum geht es in dieser Vorlesung
Grundbegriffe der praktischen
Philosophie gehört dann der Begriff des
Bösen auch dazu ich habe ihn jetzt mal
reingenommen ich glaube gehört dazu aber
wir müssen ihn natürlich kritisch
überhaupt alles in der Philosophie
überhaupt jeden Begriff kritisch
hinterfragen was nützt uns überhaupt der
Begriff des moralisch bösen zum
Verständnis unserer Handlungen und der
Welt schadet dieser Begriff nicht viel
mehr
der Beschreibung der Welt der Welt
vielleicht selbst richtet der Begriff
des Bösen am Ende vielleicht mehr
Schaden als Nutzen an ja sie nennen sich
Achse des Bösen ein Begriff um andere
Menschen
starten zu diskriminieren zu diffamieren
natürlich kann man das mit diesem
Begriff machen das wird auch permanent
getan allerdings spricht eben die
Tatsache dass wir das mit dem Begriff
machen können in meinen Augen nicht für
den Begriff wenn er sinnvoll verwendet
wird man kann diesen Begriff auch
sinnvoll verwenden und das wollen wir
jetzt versuchen in dieser heutigen
Sitzung zu tun damit er als ein
veritabler Grundbegriff der praktischen
Philosophie ausgewiesen werden kann er
muss natürlich kritisch betrachtet
werden und von missverständlichen
Bedeutung abgegrenzt werden das ist die
Aufgabe der Philosophie eine der Aufgabe
Begriffe kritisch zu diskutieren und
vielleicht sogar zu modifizieren und
sagen so ein Begriff sollten wir nicht
verwenden wir sollten anders verwenden
jetzt mache ich jemanden ganz kurze
Pause und gebt mir noch mal die
Gelegenheit zurück fragen
ja wir haben uns auch gefragt sollten
wir vielleicht nicht stattdessen lieber
verlassen und Untugenden sprechen ist
der Begriff des Bösen vielleicht nur
sinnvoll das Wort böse für Situationen
den wirklich was ganz brutales
stattfinden was un alltäglich ist das
steht aber jetzt im Kontrast zu solchen
großen Philosophen wie man kann die
sagen jeder Mensch hat ein Hang zum
Bösen auch noch eine Anlage zum Guten
aber zum Bösen diese Hand zum Bösen der
muss sich gar nicht durch brutalen Worte
manifestieren bei uns sondern der kann
im ganz kleinen unscheinbaren schon
aktuell werden nämlich wenn wir zum
Beispiel lügen wenn wir gegen das
allgemeine Lügen Verbot verstoßen im
kleinen beginnt das Böse schon
unmerklich und steigert sich dann am
Ende zu etwas monströsen zusammen
manchmal auch nicht also könnte man den
kleinen unscheinbar machen
wir müssen natürlich auch über das
moralisch gute sprechen wir können gut
in ganz verschiedenen Bedeutungen
verstehen und jetzt
gibt es wieder diese zwei Unterscheidung
die wir auch beim bösen schon
kennengelernt haben einmal im Sinne der
Nützlichkeit des Gutes tauglich
Instrumente hell brauchbar für einen
bestimmten Zweck im Gegenteil zu
schlecht es ist ein gutes Messer
griechisch Arielle Tauglichkeit Rarität
die Tauglichkeit wird aber auch der
Antike auf menschliche Handlung bezogen
das heißt einfach nur gut sein allgemein
ja da sehen sie schon gut kann man für
ganz Verschiedenes in der Antike konnte
man das für ganz Verschiedenes verwenden
man konnte sagen sein gutes Messer ein
agaton heißt gut oder ein guter Mensch
dann ist natürlich nicht ein scharfer
Mensch wie ein Messer bringt ja nichts
sondern moralisch guter Mensch der
seinen Zweck seinem Sinn seine
Bestimmung gemäß
theologische Gedanke der Zweck Erfüllung
ein Mensch der sein eigenes Bestimmung
erfüllt sondern moralische Mensch also
ein guter Mensch und ein Messer was
seine eigentliche Bestimmung erfüllt ist
ein gutes Messer Pferd was seine
eigentliche Bestimmung erfüllt ist ein
Pferd auf dem man gut reiten kann was
schnell ist was ein Zweck einfach
erfüllt so kann man gut verwenden jetzt
erst im Sinne von instrumentell tauglich
und dann gibt es eben noch diese engere
Verwendung von gut dass man sagt
moralisch lobenswert im Gegenteil zu
tadelns wird wenn man es möchte böse ist
der engere Begriff sie haben gesehen
anhand von John Stuart
man kann sogar so weit gehen und sagen
gut kann man gar nicht irgendwie genauer
bestimmen das eignet sich nicht um
definiert zu werden ist so ein
Grundbegriff jetzt können wir aber hier
ein Position zwei an diesem moralisch
also auch ah also die erste Version
tauglich instrumental brauchbar ist
natürlich auch schwach normativ
ein gutes Messer da sind wir auch
normativ zu Gange wenn wir das sagen mit
dem Messer kann ich was tun weil es wird
bewertet aber es wird nicht moralisch
bewertet und wenn wir jetzt die Frage
nach dem moralischen Bewertung uns
anschauen dann können wir natürlich je
nach Position die wir kennengelernt
haben also
Utilitarismus Tugend oder D&G es gibt
natürlich noch andere moralische
ethische ethische Paradigmen wir sind
hier ja nur in der
Handlungstheorie kann man diese
jeweilige Position des Guten weiteren
sehen also die Tourismus was ist das
Gute an einer Sachen der nutzen und das
anspruchsvolle Glück für die
Allgemeinheit wir sehen sie kann man
jetzt schon wieder groß diskutieren was
ist überhaupt nutzen was überhaupt Glück
und was ist die Allgemeinheit sind damit
alle Menschen gemeint sind damit
besondere Menschen gemeint sie sehen man
kann groß diskutieren wie sich der unter
die Terrorismus auswirken soll
entscheiden ist nur dass man über den
Nutzen definieren kann pluralisch gut
man kann es aber auch über die Jugend
Ethik machen man kann sagen die rechte
Mitte der Ausgleich von extremen
Effekten und Handlungen diese Rechte
Mitte diese ausgemittelte Mitte die ist
das Gute das moralisch gute oder man
kann sagen die Ontologie das Gute ist
wenn sich subjektive
handlungsmotivationen Maximen subjektive
Regeln unseres Handelns wenn die sich
vernünftig verallgemeinern lassen wenn
die sich nicht widersprechen wenn die
dem Sittengesetz gehorchen und wenn
vielleicht sogar noch sowas wie eine
achtungsmotivation dabei ist sie nennen
sich noch Emotionen der Achtung also sie
sehen man kann jedes gute ganz
verschieden bestimmen muss uns nicht
weit interessieren wollte damit nur
sagen wenn man hier ansetzt und der
zweiten Bedeutung dann kann man hier
noch aus oder sich sehr viel dazu sagen
es möchte ich noch mal auf das Problem
des Bösen eingehen und zwar möchte ich
jetzt aus dem neueren Forschung ihn mal
ein oder zwei Zitate vorstellen Richard
burning
bekannte amerikanische Philosoph sagt
Gary something about evil that
resistance any final comprehension
ist auch noch ein Problem des Bösen ja
wir können irgendwie das Böse nicht
richtig fassen ja das Böse entgleitet
uns als Phänomen wenn wir es begrifflich
fassen möchten es gibt keine
letztendliche gültige Erklärung dafür
warum weil das Böse hier irgendwie
rational ist ja es wurde schon gesagt
warum sollten überhaupt das Böse tun
niemand tut doch das Böse bewusst und
wenn es tut dann ist er doch nicht ganz
bei Sinn aber wie kann man sowas
irrationales überhaupt auf dem Begriff
bringen und auf den Begriff bringen
bedeutet immer es auch zu verstehen das
würde ja bedeuten das Böse zu kommen
also begreifen ist auch irgendwie
durchschauen zu können also sprich als
ein rationales oder rationalisierbares
Phänomen darzustellen und das scheint ja
beim bösen gerade gar nicht der Fall
sein wir können ja das irgendwie gar
nicht erklären wir sind ja wenn das Böse
passiert sprich wenn wirklich brutal ist
passiert so wie man sich vorstellt in
der Regel sind wir doch völlig von Kopf
gestoßen und sagt wie konnte das
passieren was ging in diesem Menschen
vor ich kann ihn nicht verstehen und wer
sagt ich kann ihn aber gut verstehen der
wird sofort erstmal Kritik auf sich
ziehen weil man ihm dann unterstellen
wird du sympathisierst ja mit dieser
Handlung natürlich ist dieses Verstehen
zweideutig man kann natürlich sagen nein
nein ich habe mir genau diese Person
angeschaut die Biografie der Person ich
habe alle Faktoren berücksichtigt ich
habe geschaut was in dem Gehirn im Kopf
vor gegen welche gründete abgewogen
wurden welche inner psychischen Kräfte
und Strategien eine Rolle gespielt haben
und wenn ich mir alles genau anschauen
dann leuchtet mir eigentlich ein dass
diese Person so handelt ja also gibt's
auch aber wir sehen diese Spannung er
sagt ich verstehe diese böse Handlung
und ich verstehe diesen Mörder der muss
aufpassen wir verstehen gebraucht ja es
darf nicht so zu verstehen so zu
verstehen sein dass es irgendwie
Sympathie ist oder irgendwie
zu verstehen ist dass man diese Mörder
gute Gründe unter so kann man ihn nicht
verstehen dürfen ohne Kritik zu bekommen
ja das ist ein Zitat und anderes diesen
auf Deutsch von Herrn Schmidt biggemann
schon ein bisschen älter dieses Detail
das Böse hat keine Logik man kann es
nicht reduzieren reduzieren heißt
logisch ableiten und definieren also
begrifflich bestimmen ja dann hätte ich
eigentlich zu Unrecht in diesem dieser
Vorlesung gebraucht weil heißt der
Grundbegriffe der praktischen
Philosophie setzt voraus dass man diese
Begriffe eigentlich definieren kann
man kann das Böse nicht mit der Logik
des Guten seines Gegenteils bannen
wenn das gelänge wäre das Böse
abschaffbar eine systematische Theorie
des Bösen ist nicht denkbar ui das ist
eine starke these ich habe aber ein Buch
geschrieben dass den Anspruch erhebt
eine Theorie des Bösen zu sein
ja
das ist jetzt eine andere Frage aber ich
will ihn nur zeigen es wird allgemein
anerkannt dass das Böse aus
philosophischer Sicht ein großes Problem
darstellt schon auf begrifflicher Ebene
ob es sich überhaupt
rational behandeln lässt und Philosophie
ist ja nichts anderes als die rationale
was auch immer jetzt rational ist
Behandlung von Grundbegriffen und ihre
kritische Diskussion anhand von
konkreten Beispielen und mit hohen
Kontrolle sprich mit Debatten das sind
diese drei Punkte die auch in der
Klausur gefragt sind ja und so kann man
natürlich das ganze jetzt auch mit dem
Begriff des Bösen tun jetzt möchte ich
Ihnen aber mal zu Konkretion damit es
ein bisschen konkreter wird das
sogenannte Milgram Experiment vorstellen
wer von ihnen hat schon mal was gehört
von Milgram Experiment also nicht so
viele ja das war ein Experiment in der
Nachkriegszeit also der hintergrund war
der zweite Weltkrieg wie konnte es
kommen das so große Teile von
Gesellschaft vor allem in Deutschland
einem Diktator einem diktatorischen
Regime ein heimfallen konnte und wie
kommt kann man das erklären das wirksam
Experiment ist natürlich ein
psychologisches Experiment muss man
immer schön unterscheiden Psychologie
und Philosophie dennoch hat es durchaus
auch als ein Beispiel eine gewisse
Bedeutung für die Philosophie ja jetzt
kann man sich das mal anschauen wir
haben hier das ist aus Wikipedia
entnommen sehr hilfreich wir haben hier
eine Versuchsperson also den
Versuchsleiter die Leiterin wir haben
hier eine ein sogenannte lehrerposition
also die Person spielt eine Lehrerin ein
Lehrer und wir haben ja eine Person die
spielt ein Schüler
der Witz ist diesen Experiment die
Versuchsperson und der Schüler die die
kooperieren die sind praktisch Teil des
Experiments die wissen worum es geht die
sind eingeweiht und der die Lehrer
Person und die ist praktisch die Person
mit der das Experiment gemacht hat also
die weiß nicht dass die beiden hier
unter einer Decke stecken sozusagen und
mit ihr eigentlich das Experiment machen
während die Lehre Person glaubt sie
würde mit der schülerperson ein
Experiment machen sie sehen schon die
schülerperson die also mit der
Versuchsleiter Person und eine Decke
steckt die ist angekabelt verkabelt und
es sieht nicht sehr bequem aus von oben
das ist ein elektrischer Stuhl das wurde
dem elektrischen Stuhl nach empfunden
und dieses ganze Experiment war
hochgradig brutal deswegen wurde es auch
zu Recht kritisiert im Anschluss weil
einige der Testpersonen da psychische
Probleme bekam ja also es war nicht so
ohne und man muss natürlich immer bei
allen wissenschaftlichen Fortschritt
auch eine Ethik des Experiments waren
sonst kann auch ein Experiment böse
werden ne also das möchte ich dazu sagen
nicht zu Hause nach nicht so nach dem
Arme und jetzt wurde ein solches Setting
eingeführt dass der Schüler sozusagen
richtige Antworten auf Fragen vom Lehrer
geben muss also die Lehre Person hat dem
Schüler Fragen gestellt es waren
vielleicht
wortfragen waren das kann man mal
genauer nachlesen und bei jedem Fehler
dürfte die Lehre Person auf Befehl des
Versuchsleiters
Stromstöße hier durch das Kabel leer
angeblich die wäre Person dachte da
werden wirklich Stromschläge dann am
Ende rüberkommen war aber alles nur
gespielt da kam gar nichts an es wurde
nur geschaut wie weit diese Person diese
Person gehen würde Stromschläge dieser
vermeintlichen schülerpersonen zu
verpassen wenn sie nicht richtig die
Aufgaben löst und ähm die Versuchsleiter
Person hat natürlich immer wieder die
personell aufgefordert
weiter mit der Spannung hoch zu gehen
und man sieht dann was diese s-person
dann geäußert hat war natürlich alles
nur gespielt weil sie selbst nicht mal
interessiert wurde bei 75 Volt Grund
sind bei 120 Volt Schmerzensschrei 150
Volt sagt die Person dass sie nicht
meine Experiment teilnehmen möchte 200
Volt Schreie die das Blut in den Adern
gefrieren lassen 300 Volt wird nicht
mehr geantworte über 330 Volt stille ich
bin kein Physiker aber ich glaube in so
einer bei so einer Spannung über 300
Volt es ist nicht so angenehm ja und es
müsste eigentlich auch anhand dieser
spielten Schmerzen schreien die Person
gemerkt haben ja dennoch hat sie fleißig
weiter gemacht und man sieht hier die
Abbrüche der Testperson als L die gesagt
hat irgendwann das kann ich nicht mehr
mit meinem Gewissen vereinbaren dass ich
immer weiter höher gehen soll obwohl ich
es befohlen bekomme von der Person Frau
die haben eigentlich die überwiegende
Mehrheit von 40 Personen hat über bei
450 Volt aufgehört so ein paar bei 300
Volt aber schauen Sie 200 Volt waren
schreite das Blut in den Adern gefrieren
lassen ja also ja und jetzt kann man da
mal so ein bisschen sagen ja was was ist
denn da passiert also ist jetzt was
passiert mit der Person l warum ist die
jetzt in so einem Setting ja dass sie
was befohlen bekommt ja machen sie
weiter hat die versucht hat die
Versuchsleiter Person gesagt das ist für
die Wissenschaft sie müssen weitermachen
hören Sie nicht auf sie ja also war
suggestiven natürlich auch ähm jetzt
endlich manipulativ aber das ging darum
ging es ja gerade in diesem Experiment
und Sie sehen also die Mehrheit ist bis
zu 54 Volt gegangen ja und es ist schon
mal eine ziemlich brutal ne und ähm
jetzt gibt sie das Fazit von diesem
mülleim er sagt das ist praktisch so das
Ergebnis jetzt dieser psychologischen
Studie die problematisch ist weil es ja
weil da eigentlich auch ein bisschen
übergriffig gehandelt wurde gegenüber
den Versuch Person er sagt ganz
gewöhnliche
nur schlicht ihre Aufgabe erfüllen und
keinerlei persönliche Feindseligkeit
empfinden die Kanten vielleicht diese
schülerperson garen können zu Handlungen
einem grausigen Vernichtungsprozess
veranlasst werden schlimmer noch selbst
wenn ihnen die zerstörerischen Folgen
ihres Handelns vor Augen geführt
schmerzensschreiben und klar bewusst
gemacht werden und wenn man ihn dann
sagt sie sollen Handlung ausführen die
im krassen Widerspruch stehen zu ihren
moralischen Grund Überzeugung zur
Verfügen doch nur vereinzelte Menschen
über genügend Standfestigkeit und der
Autorität wirksam Widerstand
entgegenzusetzen also dieser
Versuchsleiter Person die sagt
weitermachen es ist nötig für das
Experiment eine Vielzahl von Hemmungen
gegenüber dem Ungehorsam gegenüber diese
Autorität bietet und Zeug erfolgreich
dafür dass einer nicht aufmuckt
also sie kennen das phänomenos
Gruppenzwangs und hier war es natürlich
kein direkter Gruppenzwang sondern ihr
Test Zwang und darüber können wir jetzt
natürlich auch noch ein bisschen
diskutieren ja wir haben dieses Programm
Experiment etwas diskutiert wir sind
noch auf das Stanford prison Experiment
eingegangen wir haben natürlich auch die
Reichweite dieses Experiments etwas
kritisch betrachtet man muss jetzt immer
aufpassen was leiten wir davon ab welche
generellen Aussagen über die Welt der
Menschen wollen wir daraus ableiten das
ist eben nur ein psychologisches
Experiment aber ein sehr bedeutendes die
Teilnehmerzahl war nicht sonderlich groß
also hier muss man immer kritisch
genauer hinschauen wenn man jetzt daraus
etwas ableiten möchte jetzt geht's
weiter also ich wiederhole mich sie
merken sie Begriffe des Guten Bösen sind
vieldeutig und problematisch wir müssen
unterscheiden ob wir sie in moralischen
oder außenmoralischen Kontexten
verwenden der Begriff des Bösen scheint
mir nur dann sinnvoll zu sein wenn wir
andere Begriffe als sinnvoll heraus
nutzen können das darauf darum geht es
mir hier geht es nicht darum den Begriff
mit Blick auf eine absolute Moral zu
Begründung das ist nicht Gegenstand
dieser Vorlesung sonst geht darum die
Implikationen die Voraussetzungen
explizit zu machen die Begriffe auf den
Tisch zu legen die Karten auf den Tisch
der Begriffe zu legen
mit denen wir
gerechtfertigt sind einen solchen
Begriff wie das Böse als sinnvoll
ansehen moralische Normativität müssen
wir voraussetzen wir brauchen sowas wie
ein Willen man kann sie natürlich fragen
ist der Begriff des Bösen sinnvoll ohne
den Begriff des Willens kann man darüber
diskutieren aber wenn man von
individuellen Person spricht von inneren
oder externen Handlungen von komplexen
von zusammengesetzten Handlungen die man
vielleicht böse Begriff vorausgesetzt
werden zu müssen innere Handlung habe
ich schon gesagt oder äußere Handlung
Willensfreiheit auch riesen Thema hier
sprechen jemand
etwas zu wir loben eine Person wir
kritisieren eine Person für eine
Handlung das setzt voraus dass sie darin
Willensfreiheit war dass sie sich auch
anders hätte entscheiden können sie muss
alternative Möglichkeiten der
Entscheidung gehabt haben und der Willen
Entschluss muss ihr selbst zurechenbar
sein und nicht irgendwelche größeren
Hemmungen Hindernissen oder
irgendwelchen Manipulation unseres
Gehirns für das wir keine Verantwortung
tragen praktische Vernunft spielt eine
Rolle also auch wer böse handelt muss
sich dabei was denken oder es müssen
Vernunft defekt sein aber irgendwie
müssen wir auf den Begriff der
vernunftbezug nehmen es sei es dass wir
die böse Handlung durch den Begriff der
vernünftig erklären vielleicht sogar als
ein Vernunft gebrauchen als eine
Rationalität oder dass wir seit
Irrationalität bestimmen müssen auf den
Begriff der Vernunft reflektieren dann
müssen wir voraussetzen wir müssen auch
diskutieren welche Gründe für eine böse
Handlung Rolle gespielt haben rationale
und motivationale Gründe
absichtintention und auch noch das Thema
Selbsttäuschung scheint mir wichtig zu
sein zumindest dann wenn wir von
individuellen Personen oder Handlungen
sprechen man kann darüber jetzt noch
weiter diskutieren
wer oder was eigentlich moralisch böse
ist ja das möchte ich jetzt einfach mal
so zu Debatten stellen das wird nicht
Gegenstand der Klausur sein aber man
sollte darüber jetzt einfach auch mal
sich Gedanken machen sind es kollektive
Personen soziale Strukturen sind es zum
Beispiel totalitäre Regime die wir böse
nennen können sind es soziale Strukturen
die ungerecht sind wir müssen jetzt
nicht böse in den unwahren schnell die
diskriminierend sind Gesetze zum
Beispiel Gesetz sind ja Institutionen
oder soziale Strukturen kann man als
Gesetze auffassen können Gesetze
moralisch sein können Gesetze böse sein
oder sind es nicht ihr die Menschen die
dazu führen dass es zu solchen Gesetz
kam aber irgendwie hat man doch den
Eindruck wie sie Gesetze sind ein
Ausdruck einer unmoralischen Haltung
oder
ungerechtfertigen Haltung sind es
individuelle Person kann ich einzelne
Personen als böse oder Menschen als böse
bezeichnen John rolls hat in seinem Buch
als Stereo of Justice eine Theorie der
Gerechtigkeit tatsächlich von bösen
Menschen gesprochen da bin ich also aus
allen Wolken gefallen können Sie im
Register hinten nachschauen böse böse
Menschen okay müssen wir mal näher
nachgehen ist aber jetzt auch nicht
Thema unseres unsere Vorlesung ich bin
ein bisschen skeptisch Person als böse
darzustellen weil das bedeuten würde
dass sie sich nicht mehr ändern können
was also jemand böse geboren ist oder
jemand ist zeitweise böse aber wenn wir
von böser Person sprechen machen wir
eigentlich ein essentialistische Aussage
sagen du bist so und da bin ich ein
bisschen vorsichtig Menschen
grundsätzlich als böse zu bezeichnen
anders sieht jetzt aus mit Handlungen ja
Handlungen kann man schon unmoralisch
böse nennen aber man könnte zum Beispiel
auch sagen kann ich eine Handlung
wirklich ansehen dass sie böse ist
könnte sich da nicht dahinter ein gutes
Motiv verbergen also müssen wir
vielleicht eine nicht doch nur unsere
Maxime oder Intention sprich unseren
Willen in den Blick nehmen ist der
eigentlich im Grunde weil der ja alles
von dir gute der Böse zu nennen man
könnte sagen der Wille von einzelnen
Personen fundiert die hat auf dem Willen
aus dem Willen entstehen die Hand und
die werden dadurch motiviert die
Handlungen konstituieren oder die
Maximen konstituieren auch die Person
die wiederum konstituiert kollektive
Person also ist am Ende alles in den
Maximen von individuellen Person Grund
gelegt was die Frage nach dem Bösen
angelangt darüber wollen wir auch ganz
kurz diskutieren
wir haben darüber diskutiert was dafür
spricht das eine das andere wenn man
überhaupt schon Begriff des Bösen
annehmen möchte oder das Wort sinnvoll
verwenden möchte worauf es sich beziehen
kann
sie fragen ob alles am Ende hier unter
Punkt 4 in den Maximen den Intentionen
den Willen der individuellen Person
fundiert ist und dann praktisch nach
oben in Handlungen individuelle Person
kollektive Person konstituiert weil es
praktisch zurückgeführt werden kann auf
individuelle Intentionen oder bis
wirklich schon auf diesen jeweiligen
Ebenen stabil gewissermaßen die
Berechtigung gibt von unmoralisch zu
sprechen von eigentlich unmoralisch
nicht sondern abgeleiteten Sinn das
müssen wir uns natürlich immer Fragen es
gibt zwei Bedeutung von bösen das ist
eine kurze Wiederholung das natürliche
Übel des malen Physikum physische
natürlich übel Krankheiten defekte
Schwächen
das moralische übel malung Moralen
morddiebstahl Missgunst Schadenfreude
Schadenfreude deswegen weil Aristoteles
sagt schadenfreude ist innen drin sich
schlecht wie auch Missgunst das ist
nicht ein zu viel oder zu wenig von
etwas nicht irgendwie die verfehlte
Mitte sondern das ist intrinsisch
schlecht
und genauso kann man natürlich auch vom
natürlichen guten und von moralischen
guten spricht analog dazu also von bonum
Physikum und von Ordnung Moral auch so
kann man dann das sagen alles Gute das
natürlich gut gute ist ihm das
Instrument hellgute oder das vielleicht
gesunde das stark das adäquate und das
moralisch gute ist eben das
großherziger kann man es tugendhafte das
vernünftige das ich weiß nicht was
können sich dann eben je nach ethischen
Paradigma dann die Sachen hier einsetzen
das was die größten Nutzen für die
Menschheit bringen weiß meiste Glück
unserer kleinen also das ist ganz
wichtig zwischen diesen zwei Bedeutungen
zu unterscheiden das ist natürlich eine
Frage des Typs ah für die Klausur sowas
kann in dem Teil A gestellt werden jetzt
gibt es zwei Auffassung des moralisch
bösen das habe ich auch schon erklärt
gehabt das
Böse könnte auch gefasst werden nur als
ein Mangel an guten ein Defizit das ist
einfach nicht das Gute in der Vollform
das ist die privatisationstheorie
privatation heißt Beraubung aber da wird
das Gute einfach etwas getrübt und indem
wir das Gute zurücknehmen das Gute
einschränken je mehr wir das Gute
einschränkt desto mehr entsteht das Böse
also komplementär die ergänzen sich
letztendlich im Idealfall haben 100% gut
ja
man muss natürlich jetzt recht gesagt
wurde zumindest in der mittelalterlichen
Tradition immer von guten her sehen das
Gute ist immer dem Bösen überlegen nur
daran kann das Böse bestimmt werden eben
als weniger Gutes aber es hat keine
eigene Substanz das Böse nach dieser
privatationstheorie es kann immer nur
mit Blick auf das Gute als ein Mangel
daran sichtbar werden wie so ein
Schatten wie so ein Gegenstand ein
Schatten wird so kann man sich nach
dieser Auffassung des böse vorstellen
ein Beispiel wäre hier Trägheit und
Faulheit das Gute zu tun Triebe und
Neigungen die uns überwältigen
trainieren Instinkte und so weiter und
so fort wo einfach unsere vernünftig
nutzen zugekommen geht's die
perversionstheorie das Böse ist demnach
eine bewusste das ist immer die Frage
eine Umkehrung eine Perversion der guten
Ordnung ein Beispiel wäre die
Rationalisierung eine unmoralischen
Handlung als Gericht oder garmoralisch
da können sie wieder das
merkm-experiment Denken
hier hat sich die Versuchsperson das so
zurechtgelegt dass es für sie irgendwie
in Ordnung ist dass sie diese Stromstöße
zu fügt da sonst hätte sie es ja nicht
gemacht ja sie wollte ja nicht bewusst
dass der anderen Person Schmerzen
zufügen sondern sie hat sich in der
Situation gesehen dass sie
gerechtfertigt war das zu tun sonst
hätte sie es nicht getan man kann
natürlich wieder Fragen war das eine
Folge von Willensschwäche aber ich
glaube dass das nicht sonderlich
hilfreich ist sondern dass man es
tatsächlich als Rationalisierung ansehen
muss kann man sich natürlich fragen will
man das Böse bewusst tut man das Böse
sehen den Auges das mag solche Fälle
geben aber auch die Menschen die das
Böse sind in August tun glauben dass das
noch irgendwie gut für sie sei also es
ist irgendwie Schwert vorzustellen dass
jemand das Böse tut im vollen
Bewusstsein darüber dass das Böse nie
etwas Gutes sein kann selbst für die
Person die das Böse tut wer das wüsste
und dann trotzdem das Böse täte der
müsste tatsächlich im Sinne der
Willensschwäche verstanden werden weil
dann wirklich alle Argumente für das
Gute sprechen würden und keins für das
Böse wer im Bewusstsein dessen dass das
Böse einfach nur schaden kann auch der
eigenen Person und den anderen trotzdem
das Böse tut den kann man nicht
irgendwie
vernünftig halten ne da muss man sagen
das ist irgendwie ein Paradox so wie es
Davidson gut anhand dieser Diskussion
der binnenschwäche glaube aber das ist
ebenso nicht ist sondern ich glaube dass
selbst wenn man das den Eindruck hat in
der bösen unmoralischen Situation im
Setting dass das nicht ganz okay ist ich
sag schon nicht ganz okay das Böse zu
tun das fängt schon an da versucht man
es zu verharmlosen dann versucht man
Gründe anzuführen warum man es eben doch
da darf und es gibt immer genug Gründe
die man herbeizitieren kann um dann doch
die eigentlich unmoralische oder
illegitim oder wie auch immer nicht
korrekte Hand in einem anderen
gerechtfertigen vielleicht sogar in
einem moralischen Licht erscheinen zu
lassen ein Beispiel ist zum Beispiel
wenn man sagt ja jetzt breche ich in der
Bank ein ich weiß zwar dass ich das
nicht machen soll aber ich wurde
ungerecht behandelt ich habe zu wenig
Geld ich stelle nur die Gerechtigkeit
wieder her und außerdem kriegen meine
armen Verwandten auch noch was davon und
ich schmeiße auch noch ein Bündel
tausende Euroscheine aus dem Fenster ja
und ich spende auch noch 10.000 ja
eigentlich damit nur das gut so könnte
man das dann tun ja es gibt genug
Strategien dann wird man dann immer sehr
sehr erfinderisch und sehr kreativ um
eine eigentlich nicht korrekte Handlung
dann doch einen korrekten Licht
erscheinen zu lassen man braucht doch
Gründe die dafür sprechen ja ist das
Böse rational das möchte ich mit Ihnen
zum Schluss noch kurz diskutieren dann
machen wir noch kurze Abstimmung was
spricht dafür also man kann sagen
religiösesten Mangel an Vernunft ja wer
böse handelt es rational das wäre dann
so privationstheorie der kann nicht ganz
bei Sinn sein das Böse entspringt
eigentlich an Denkfehler das Böse sprich
entspringt aus Willensschwäche oder es
entspringt durch unkontrollierte Neigung
und Triebe und das ist ja irgendwie
rational das Problem ist diese privation
ist uns da nicht so ohne weiteres
zurechenbar Stichwort Zurechenbarkeit
das kommt noch dran oder wir sagen es
böse ist ein spezieller gebraucht der
Vernunft der perversionstheorie z.B
setzen uns Instrument Telefonat ein bei
einem Banküberfall oder wir
rationalisieren die Missgunst im Sinne
von gerechtfertigter Empörung das
Problem ist hier dass wir die Auffassung
haben das Rationalität innen drin sich
irgendwie noch aktiv ist ja also
irgendwie scheint die Vernunft auf gute
in angelegt sein
und jetzt dürfen sie mal kurz abstimmen
ich weiß nicht ist die Umstimmung noch
aktiv oder muss ich sie noch aktivieren
das kann ich leider nicht sehen geht's
ja okay dann machen wir jetzt eine kurze
Pause
ja wir haben gesehen die Mehrheit von
ihnen ca 60 Prozent sagt böse Handlungen
können wir als rational bezeichnen die
vertragen sich mit Rationalität und 40%
von ihnen sagen nein nicht ich finde das
jeder von ihnen da irgendwie gute
Argumente auf seiner ihrer Seite hat ja
ich hatte gesagt wir haben irgendwie
Zögerung gezögern das also unmoralische
Handlung als rational zu bezeichnen weil
man das vernünftigerweise nicht tun
sollte unsere Vernunft gebietet uns
nicht unmoralisch zu handeln auf der
anderen Seite
neigen mir dazu doch irgendwie
unmoralische oder sogar böse handelt in
Verbindung zu bringen weil wir sehen das
häufig Täterinnen und Täter äußerst
geliebt vorgehen wenn Sie eine
unmoralische oder sogar böse Handlung
tun da ist die Vernunft schon im Spiel
vielleicht ist sie viel geleitet das
muss man sich fragen aber sie ist
irgendwie mit drin und sonst hätte man
gar nicht zu dieser Hand kommen können
das ist eine Spannung und die müssen wir
auflösen und das werden wir auch tun
allerdings ist eine übernächsten oder
übernächsten Vorlesung wenn es um die
Selbsttäuschung geht ich glaube nämlich
dass der Begriff der Selbsttäuschung der
Schlüssel zum Verständnis dieses
Problems ist in der nächsten Sitzung
gehen wir auf moralische
zurrechenbarkeit und Verantwortung mehr
ein sie haben gesehen diese Frage wird
vor allem dann wirklich dringlich wenn
es um unmoralische Dinge geht wenn es um
Schuldzuweisung gibt dann geht es häufig
um Verantwortung ich glaube gar nicht so
häufig wenn es um das Gute geht da
spricht man nicht so häufig von
verantwortlich ich glaube man wird erst
dann als touringbare Instanz relevant
wenn es ums unmoralische um schlechte
oder uns böse geht inwiefern können uns
unsere Regel schlechten bösen Handlung
zugerechnet werden welche Bedingungen
was muss vorausgesetzt werden damit uns
eine Handlung zugerechnet werden kann
das ist natürlich wieder das
begriffsnetz wie sie da sehr in den
Spiel bringen können um das zu erklären
dir geht es nicht darum ob die Begriffe
wirkliche Bedeutung haben ob es wirklich
die Objektivität der Moral gibt das
diskutieren wir nicht sondern nur dass
wenn wir die sinnvolle sinnvolle
Verwendung von böse annehmen was wir
dann als ebenfalls sinnvoll voraussetzen
müssen dann bedanke ich mich für die
Aufmerksamkeit bis zur nächsten vorlesen